let's get on the lines here we're gonna
continue we're going to we've got
Julianne in Florida how are you good
thanks thank you how are you oh we're
focusing not finished how can we help
you today
okay so blessed I got through to you
guys today because this was kind of like
somewhat urgent
my boyfriend and I had been together for
five years we're currently saving to buy
a house we have 12,000 so far it was our
goal for the last two years and of
course life happened last year and we
weren't able to so then we started
receiving again this year I have to move
out we have to be on our own I want to
get a house we're chill right now I'm
with my mom I have a I have a
ten-year-old son so you know things have
just been you know I've been kind of
I've been living foolishly you know and
my mom introduced me to Financial Peace
University a couple years ago and it
really woke me up and turned me around
and changed my mentality on how I want
to live my life and what where I want to
go and think well I was able to kind of
like bring him on board as well because
we were both kind of living foolish oh
you weren't focused or you know
determined to do anything but spend our
money anyway so he's got a used truck we
both have used vehicles we don't have
any debt thank God we're on baby step
three
along with saving debt for the down
payment of our house
he has a used truck that we put a new
transmission in last year and now it
needs something else we're still waiting
on the diagnosis from the mechanic but
he's thinking worst-case scenario is a
three thousand dollar bill he wants to
he's adamant about trying to talk me
into getting a new truck I don't want to
I mean yeah so let me get this straight
you and your boyfriend are living at
home with your mother in the y'all are
trying to make moves together to go buy
something and you guys are not currently
married right now my hearing is correct
correct marriage is on the table though
marriage has been discussed we both want
to get married okay we want to have our
house first thank you
ohayo because i know what you gonna do I
mean I just hold on wait for it but but
let me talk so he wants to buy a new
truck he wouldn't mind he shouldn't fix
it he should he should buy a new truck
okay when I don't think that's a good
idea
why don't you think it's a good idea
give me the two reasons
well what I'm scared of is that we're
gonna lose the money that we've saved
obviously we will because if it's going
to go into a new truck but also if we
are not buying it cash
you know I'm we're not going to be able
to qualify for as much of a house as we
would as we would had we if we didn't
have any debt to income ratio right
right well okay so here's the reality
let me let me here you know and I'll
toss with you so the truck it would be a
dumb idea that would be something that
that is counter to what you're doing the
problem is is you guys are playing house
and you are you are in the process of
trying to make decisions and you right
now there's no unity and so I would say
definitely do not buy a home until you
guys are married just bottom line I
wouldn't you you are you're not united
right now and so a truck or something
along those lines not only would it mess
up your qualification but you know right
now you guys need to make it's please
smart you said it you said it uh nice I
don't I don't need to say that get it
okay
hey I was tongue-tied when we come back
from the break I'm gonna untie stuff get
him to tell us what he was thinking on
our last call we had a lady that was
living with her boyfriend or they were
talking about buying a home together and
it was one of those AOS started blood
pressure went up I could I could feel it
and I would it was he come back here
anthe I want you to uh I want you to
talk about this what do you people who
are living together or what what's your
thoughts on this as they're trying to
move forward and do financial things
together yeah man you know I want to
thank you for stepping in and allowing
me to calm down a little bit because the
reason why I got so passionate about
that message is because I see the road
that she's going down
and it bothers me because this younger
generation especially within my
generation at 20 and 30 year old we feel
that it is okay and that it is a good
move to mood move in with someone but
let's backtrack on that call they are
they don't live on their own they live
with their mother okay and so for me one
here's a very first thing that I see
this we're not taking care of our
priorities and so our priorities is
ourself we need to build our self up
first and do things right why do you
want to go out there and build something
with someone that can bounce on you
tomorrow I'm sorry for us non hit people
what does bounce me I mean as in like
leave me tomorrow thank you okay and
people can say well if I'm married he
can leave me tomorrow yeah yeah but the
the the likelihood of that happening is
nowhere near to what a boyfriend and
girlfriend can do to each other and so
here's here's my thing and here's just
my suggestion to the world before you
try to build something together build
something on your own and and when you
build something on your own do it the
right way when it comes to marriage as
far as in building our home and house
why do you want to purchase a house with
a boyfriend or a girlfriend you want to
build something with your husband with
your wife with your partner with your
life loan partner so that when you build
something you can build something on top
of that we've we've seen stories we're
boyfriend and girlfriend moved in
together bought houses bought cars and
in along in it was a huge Oh literally I
can remember a couple that were dating
bought a car together
it got so contentious that they were
rotating the car every other week after
they broke up and so eventually someone
just took over the car and bought it out
so you're right from a stability
purposes it doesn't make sense yeah when
you can go to the justice of the peace
and go on to get the I Do's done yeah
yeah yeah that mean and then and then
here's the thing man just get married
you know if you guys are already living
each other and acting like you marry
living like you marry just get married
yo go down to the courthouse and get
married and be and do life together
because
you have to ask have to ask this
question if you're living together and
you don't know the marriage stuff but
you then you're not married well what's
the problem are their doubts inside your
head so why are you living together if
you have doubts so so just just just get
yourself right build yourself up
together and then get married and then
go out there and build something big
there we go
do you feel better now I feel a lot
better thank you for Lowrie you were you
were you were all twitching and
everything at the break hell he was
looking at how I can get this done